here with liam neeson yeah so he was in
the interview and and
he told a story about something that
happened to him or
someone close to him however many years
ago and basically the lady had been
raped by somebody who was black
great
great
by somebody who was black and he um he i
can't remember what tool he reached
where he grabbed the tool and he was
looking for any black person to say
something wrong to him so he can sort of
carry out the scapegoat
do you know what's funny though do you
know what's interesting though about
that
and i've said
that's not something that black people
do
so if one if one of our family members
was graped by a white person we wouldn't
be like i'm gonna look for any white
person to do that
that's not something that we do
that's something that comes with
uh being white they have that majority
privilege privilege
they have that that privilege that
they're able to do things
that other people can't because of them
being
in that space they're being privileged
so like you said black people wouldn't
do that because if a black person
wouldn't did that oh often
no black person would do that you don't
know no let me tell you something okay
you don't you don't know i tell you why
i don't charlie yeah black people have
like a collective like yeah
they have like a thing like we have a
collective thing it's like if an arab or
a moroccan person was to grape one of my
family i'm not looking for all moroccan
people that i don't give a damn what one
again
you might i mean look i'm not saying you
will but you might even no but the thing
is you see that the shootings are
happening at buffalo shooting
you had dylan roof
like when you read their manifestos they
talk about
black people in a general in a general
term right as a community as a community
so they're like oh we wanted to get rid
of him
and
but i'm going to go somewhere deep now
but
the one thing
that a lot in my in my personal point of
view uh one thing that a lot of um white
people don't get about black people
is that we don't see them
the way they see us
generally so it's like we don't see
white people like oh we don't we don't
do mass shootings of white people
black people it's like oh because i
wanted to kill we we don't see you the
same way that some of you not all of you
see us we just don't like it's just like
we just don't see it that way
because because you mentioned shootings
how do you see each other
like so we see it like and i've said
this and i said this one listen it's a
very deep one i said this black people
are more willing to shoot another black
person than they are a white person yeah
wow just to be just to be real yeah
because if you look at the statistics
most crime is interracial right so
intra-racial means you're more likely to
commit a crime against someone who of
your own race black people are more
likely to do that against their own but
also it's proximity though so
you know if so that's why i said why
people stop being scared stop being
scared of black people doing some [ __ ]
we ain't
we don't think like that we just don't
to a degree because to a degree i feel
like it's human nature what liam neeson
did we may not all act on it but take
911 for an example
like we all looked at people from middle
east were like if if somebody who looks
arab was to get on a train we would
everyone black white asian whoever it is
we all looked at them
we decided especially if they had a
package on them so i feel like
we may not all go there but we like you
you mentioned earlier we all have racial
prejudices prejudice exactly we do you
know what i mean so i feel like that was
the same in the liam neesh neeson
situation we may not do it you and i or
the black community may not necessarily
feel we can or whatever but it would run
through our minds if i was that enraged
if i if my sister came from a a bar and
there's only 10 men there i'm going to
the bar and in my mind any one of them
can get it so it may not be the exact
same situation as liam neeson but
it's not that we're not that far far off
from did you know
could it just be an overreaction and
first it obviously didn't do it yeah
yeah he didn't no i didn't i didn't know
and did he not offer this up as like an
actual like interview that wasn't even a
question he was kind of yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was so it was getting into the
psychology of what you were talking
about yeah so for me i mean i don't
remember i remember the outline of the
story not in depth yeah but for me
that's a bit like he's angry it's an
immediate thing you're going to be angry
immediately yeah so you're making the
emotion his mindset is obviously warped
but the crime is also warped 100 but i'm
saying what what i'm trying to like some
and i say this a lot the one of the
things i try to let um if i speak to
white people because you know i spoke
with tommy robinson and i've spoken to
like sargon of akkad like
a lot of fear
that i feel that white people have
is that black people are going to do the
same [ __ ] to them that they've done to
us historically it's like black people
have been quote-unquote free
yeah mm-hmm
for decades
there's no sleeper cells of black people
looking to kill white people like
i've not heard of this as a white man
i've not i've not had this like fear
projected onto me i don't think it right
but i've heard it before but the thing
is what you're in britain though yeah
right so if you look if you are scared
of black people so you look at america
and you get mass shootings like the
buffalo
like dylan roof
and
stuff of that stuff of the ilk right
where they when when you read their
manifestos and you read their fears
right and they say black people or the
mexicans or the jews or what it's like
is that white people or americans
that's white americans
okay so it's not all white people no no
of course it's not all white people i'm
just saying that
the comment you're making isn't about
british white people no i'm certain no
no no i'm saying all right so we can
specif we can specify it to american
white people
american white people need to understand
that black people in america have been
there for a very long time
and they haven't been plotting and
planning and scheming against you
they've just been saying you know what
let's just do our thing leave us alone
you know i mean and so it's like i just
want
white american people you can say to
just say you know what just chill the
hell out yeah i actually i can i can
agree on that because for example if you
go to france now right especially paris
um people wouldn't tend to not talk more
to girls for example wearing a scarf
because of islamophobia that is
happening there it's a huge thing there
that
they even wanted to eradicate mosques
all over paris just because of what
happened previously and that's how they
treat what happened previously off the
horizon
and
grapes that happen and all that you know
so people tend more to hate that
particular community even knowing that
they haven't done anything to them you
know just because of the whole mass
community that okay one muslim person
did this so maybe the whole community is
like that it's a stigma
but the thing is with that though this
is a thing about
i've always said about immigration right
um people are xenophobic a lot of people
are xenophobic by nature no matter what
color race culture you are
um
people are xenophobic and so if
something different moves in into their
territory they're more likely to be a
bit suspicious of it do you know what
i'm saying like
it's just
it's just kind of like a normal thing
and i think
especially with islam in france
that's the thing exactly especially in
that place but i i think that when
people people need to understand we talk
about cultures before earlier on right
we're saying people in like you know um
south america in the in the jungle or
whatever will have a different culture
to people outside of that
i think more so what you're getting is a
culture clash
100 and people understand that a
different culture is moving in on our
culture we don't see things the same we
don't praise the same god we don't eat
the same food we don't and so if there's
a fear there that's what it is i think
and the change also like i was
mentioning to alexa the other day the
reason why there seems to be a push back
is that for example
we see in nature when you change from
the seasons from winter to summer it
won't be winter tuesday and summer the
next day there's a gradual change right
in the same way with other changes like
immigration and stuff the reason why the
pushback because the change is happening
way too fast we just had you know gay
rights have the right to get married was
it 2010
i don't know yeah that was yeah then all
of a sudden now we've got now we've got
transgenderism it's way too fast then
this is where the that's where the
schism comes isn't it yeah yeah exactly
i like your analogies thank you thank
you thank you yeah it's like it's like
when things happen too fast
human beings don't get a chance to kind
of digest it yeah and understand exactly
and process it and understand exactly
what's going on when it happens like
okay today we're fine tomorrow we got
five thousand
chinese people on our borders we're like
yo
yeah what was going on yeah what was
going on yeah and that's just that's the
nature of human beings